let's bring in coach Thibodeau the
Timberwolves head coach is they won last
night they beat the Nuggets they get the
Rockets coming up what do you make of
Russell Westbrook's triple-double this
year coach as an analyst if you were
looking at how big a deal is this do
back to back years amazing you know and
I think you know I read his comments
yesterday and to be honest I agree with
him it's reaction to the ball he's he is
amazing
you know the rebounding that's not an
easy thing to do for a guard and he does
it and not just with the rebounding
loose balls pursuit of the ball you know
like coming up with steals I mean you
have to be aware of him at all times
he's he's an incredible player but I
know you can pad your stats offensively
but it I not many guys pad their stats
with assists in rebounds scoring you do
right what he puts in just the way he
plays the game it's one of the things
that you really respect about him he's
he's so fierce on every play you know
and he's easing in that tack mode all
the time so it's he puts pressure on you
and you know if you if you bring the
second defender he'll drop it off it you
know he just his reaction to the ball is
is amazing but his attack is I think
what makes him who he is he's you know
like it's not an easy thing to do and to
do it every night it's pretty incredible
alright a formal introduction the
Minnesota Timberwolves head coach Tom
Thibodeau the Continental Tire coaches
corner congratulations getting into the
postseason give me the pregame speech
last night
well thanks Dan first of all and then at
that point of season there's not any big
speeches you know I like I might think
to those guys was I was proud of the way
that they fought all year when Jimmy
went down I was right after the all-star
break and we had a very tough schedule
down the stretch and then we lost Jeff
Teague for a while also and then but
just the way they fought and held it
together and the last month was I mean
it was pretty crazy in the West all the
teams were pretty close together and
you're fighting every night and just to
come out in the end and still be in I
thought was a great accomplishment I
thought our team got a lot
better as the season went along and of
course when Jimmy went out there was an
opportunity for some other guys to grow
and gain valuable experience so I think
that the whole stretch run was good for
us it's good preparation or we have a
lot of young guys that don't have
experience in the playoffs but the last
month is basically it's been like the
playoffs every night I know you love
your defense if you could pick anybody
that you've ever coached or coached
against who could play defense on James
Harden yeah who would you have yeah you
know in over the years there's been like
so many like unbelievable players they
you know like when you get a superstar
player yeah it's almost impossible to
guard him individually she has to do it
with your team and it's that it ends up
being the team commitment yeah when I
was in New York you know of course the
the battles with you know Michael Jordan
and then of course you had Kobe and you
hard in and LeBron you know when I was
in Boston it's those guys are you know
you can defend them great and you can
send the second defender and they still
can make shots and make plays sometimes
you can defend them perfectly you just
got to try to make them work for what
they're gonna get and then they've seen
every defense there is so you also have
to change things up on them but I think
the way harden has really it's pretty
amazing is it because it's his power and
strength to go along with the vision and
his ability to shoot the ball and just
draw fouls and and things like that you
had to be very disciplined against them
but then when you couple him with Chris
Paul yet you're talking about two elite
players they can virtually break your
defense down off the dribble so you you
have to be very disciplined against them
and then of course the way they shoot
the three and then Capella's pressure on
the rim those are all things that you
have to be alert for and and aware of
better offensive player Jordan or harden
oh you know I think those things are
really tough I think it's it the debate
becomes better when James is done
playing
and then you can you know you can
measure but it's hard to compare anyone
to Michael just because of you know the
championships you know what he did for
that team but what James is doing is
pretty amazing also did Jordan ever give
D talk trash to the bench when when he
was playing always different era all
those guys were you know it's it's not
it was and it was and there was a
physicality to go along with the trash
talk so you know you were it was you
know he's such a fierce competitor but
yet during that era there were a lot of
guys Byrd was like that too there was no
B what would they say to you I can't say
we had some guys that were going back
pretty good too yeah I mean I think
that's what you love I mean you know and
in sports when there's great competition
when two teams are really going at it
and there's a you know on every play and
sometimes it's funny when you go back
and you watch some of those games and
it's it's so different than it is today
you know those guys it's the physicality
of the game was a lot different than it
is today but virtually you can't touch
guys and use your hands and you know
block cuts the way you did back then
it's really the the offense has gained a
big advantage from that Phil Jackson
told me this a couple years ago when he
was on a book tour he said today's rules
Jordan would average 45 a game I'd say
that's probably accuracy you know like
the thing is when you think about it it
like there was always a lot of grabbing
and holding with him you had to you know
he would be the way the rules are today
he would probably average 15 free throws
a game at a minimum do you wish we still
had those rules in place now is there
too much often I think that the rule
changes have been good it's really
changed the game and like if you can
recall the nine
that you really had like power forwards
play in the small forward position and
now it's flipped the other way where you
basically have small forwards playing
the power forward position and you have
a lot more shooting on the floor
everyone's basically for out one in with
the one big you know rolling to the rim
putting pressure on the rim to pull
people in so it's opened up the game
there's you know which is the intention
of the rule changes was to open it up
because it did become probably a little
over over the top in terms of
physicality and so but I thought that
the rule changes were good for the game
and what we're seeing with the
three-point shooting now has really
changed things are are they better
shooters now or they're just certain
shooters who are the best that we've
ever seen because I don't know if
they're better shooters per set
everybody wants to shoot the three I
mean this must drive you crazy where it
feels like everybody comes in saying
they want to learn to shoot the three or
they want to you know be the designated
three-point shooter well I you know the
interesting thing to me is the
development of the big guys it's it's
amazing with laying we have one that's
pretty amazing in Carl he has it all put
it on the floor you know he can Euro
step he shoots the three great he can
play back to the basket and you seen a
lot of the bigs that really have guard
like skills and so it's it's become a
big part of the game and you know and I
think you know players are working on
their all-around skills and then the
challenge is to find the draymond greens
and those type of guys who you know we
have one in Gibson they you know the
that can play defense also so when you
downsize you're not sacrificing your
defense in that you know I think that's
one of the things like with the Warriors
when dream on goes to the five they
don't sacrifice their defense and that's
what makes them so good Steph Curry best
shooter you ever seen well you know I
had the good fortune to be around he and
clay with USA basketball and you know it
and when you're up close with that
and you watch some shoe it's it's hard
to believe like how deep they can shoot
it and how quick they can get it off and
then oftentimes what you realize is that
in transition they can pull up from
anywhere and probably might not be a
great shot for a lot of people but for
them it is I mean they they can make
them so I I'd like to see those two in
it and have a shootout or shooting
contest because pretty close between
those two I'd like to have you and Luke
Walton have a voice off coach it'd be
close I mean this would be Ali Frazier I
mean and he's a younger guy that voice
is gonna get a little deeper I think Hey
look who's done a terrific job with the
Lakers he's really a good guy too well
Congrats I know you got homework to do
with James Harden you know what I'm
gonna try I think you should make him go
right every left-handed guy you all we
always go you force him right like
nobody says about a right-handed guy hey
poor seem left that's pretty good right
yeah like Ginobili you know you can make
him go right all you want he's gonna
spin back around and go left off hey
Congrats
all right that's a Tom Thibodeau
Continental Tire Coach's Corner anytime
you'd face a left-hander force him right
pours but you know being a right-hander
I wanted them to force me left because I
practiced that but I'm guessing James
Harden practices that where but he's so
big and strong it's even hard to you
know force him to go right because he
lowers that shoulder and he's got such a
good body their Continental Tire Coach's
Corner whether you're student alumni are
all-around fan Continental Tire has a
tire to get you to the big game proud
sponsor of 32 college basketball teams
for more information all the great
things great products visit Continental
Tire calm vivid oh but they call him
Tibbs for more Dan Patrick show
the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]